نحن نتكلم هنا عما اعتقد انه اصعب جزء من
عملك وهو انك توسل اشخاصا الى منطقه حرب
واماكن سيئه كل يوم كم من الوقت تقضي انت
والعاملون هنا للتفكير في سلامه
الصحفيين هذا على الاغلب اهم بل اخطر جزء
من المهمات التي نقوم بها نحن جيش متطوع
هنا الناس يريدون ان يعملوا في هذا المجال
انهم ينضمون لسي ان ان من اجل القيام بهذا
اتلقى في اغلب الاوقات طلبات من اربعه او
خمسه اشخاص يرغبون في ان نرسلهم في مهمات
ذات مخاطر عاليه ونحن نختار الاشخاص وفقا
لحتمية
الموارد الكافيه التي توفر لنا الحريه
والمرونه للقيام بكل ذلك فالناس والموظفون
هنا يتوقعون من سي ان ان القدره على
القيام بذلك وغير مسائل التوظيف والامن
والسلامه هناك سؤال واحد مهم هل سنذهب الى
هناك ام لا كيف تقرر اذا تعلق الامر بمكان
ما خارج الحدود بعض الاماكن تكون خارج
الحدود وعندما لا نعرف بشان وجود اتصالات
محليه على الارض او انه يمكننا وضع خطه
هروب او انسحاب وكذلك عندما نعلم عن عدم
وجود مكان للاختباء او ان الميدان ليس
امنا او عدم وجود التكنولوجيا اللازمه
التي تساعدنا او عندما لا يكون لدينا
اتصالات او شبكه محليه ولو توفرت لدينا
بعض او كل هذه الاشياء فهناك فرص جيده
للقيام بهذه العمليه بنجاح نحن نفتخر بس
سجلنا في هذا المجال ولكن علينا ان نتوقع
انه في اي لحظه قد يحدث شيء فظيع ونحن بكل
تاكيد نتكلم عن استهداف الصحفيين ولكن
هناك العديد منهم وهم غير مستهدفين ولكنهم
في مواقف خطيره مثل اسرائيل وغزه هؤلاء
الصحفيون لم يكونوا مستهدفين ولكنهم ماتوا
في مكان مليء بالقنابل والمتفجرات فبالطبع
يوجد خطر مرتفع هناك ولكن اظن ان ما تشير
اليه هو زياده استهداف الصحفيين وهناك
اناس باتوا يستهدفون لاحتجاز خلافا
للاضرار الجانبيه المعتاده وهذا شيء علينا
التنبه اليه اريدك ان تتكلم عن الموظفين
هنا للناس الذين لا يعرفونهم كما نعرفهم
نحن من هم هؤلاء الموظفون الذين يختارون
الذهاب الى هذه الاماكن
بانفسهم انه امر مثير للاهتمام فالكثير من
الصحفيين يريدون القيام بمثل هذه المهمات
المهمه والخطيره لمشاركتها مع العالم
ولدينا الكثير من الصحفيين الذين يفكرون
بهذ الطريقه وانا ممتن لوجودهم معنا وفي
سي ان ان واماكن اخرى هناك اناس بحاجه ماس
للقيام بهذا النوع من العمل وهم ملتزمون
بالقصه انهم يعرفون اناسا في تلك البلدان
وهم حقا متحمسون للقيام بمثل هذه المخاطره
كما انهم على يقين من مدى خطورتها ولكنهم
يشعرون ان من واجبهم الاهتمام بهؤلاء
الناس وبقصه انه اسلوب صعب للعيش ولكنه
طريق جيده من اجل صحافه
استثنائيه